und sie locken ihren hells angels
kollegen ihren rocker bruder
heimtückisch in eine falle schießen ihm
von hinten in den kopf zerstückeln seine
leiche und werfen die einbetonierten
teile dann in kanal und rein heute
beginnt der prozess sechs rocker stehen
wegen mordes mordversuchs und
strafvereitelung vor dem landgericht in
duisburg hier noch einmal der ganze fall
ein mutmaßlicher mörder auf der flucht
ramin nektar palast er verhöhnt deutsche
fahnder und auch seine opfer auf
instagram für seine 122 tausend follower
postet der 33-jährige dreist videos und
fotos in denen er sich im iran stolz
sind freiheit zeigt dann ein ausschnitt
aus dem film forrest gump in dem forst
weg läuft das projekt passt das nennt
sich auf der flucht sein es folgt ein
foto im liegestuhl unter wasser das ist
abtauchen und das ist noch nicht alles
am ende der post rocker insta story ein
video in dem der hells angel breit
könnten mit sonnenbrille im liegestuhl
am pool league dazu schreibt er und wie
nennt sich das als wolle er damit sagen
ich bin nicht auf der flucht ich bin
nicht abgetaucht ich genieße mein leben
das geht auch nur weil der iran eigene
landsleute nicht ausliefert weitere
videos auf seinem instagram account
zeigen ihn mit seinem lamborghini posen
einmal drehte auf dem heißen motor ein
spiegelei wohl um allen zu zeigen was er
für ein toller kerl ist sein ganzer
körper ist tätowiert neben üblichen
hells angels symbolen ziert auch ein
hakenkreuz seinen oberarm gefahndet wird
nach héctor parra ist wegen des mordes
an km im jahr 2014 dessen leichnam
zerstückelt im rhein gefunden wurde bild
reporter frank schneider war vor ort
dabei für uns begibt er sich nochmal auf
spurensuche an die verschiedenen auf in
der orte der leichenteile nach aussagen
des kronzeugen und auch nach ansicht der
ermittler der mordkommission hier in
duisburg von die täter damals genau in
diesem bereich mit ihrem auto und dann
gingen sie mit den leichenteilen dem
torso und einem arm des ermordeten
rockers zu dieser brücke und dann
trieben danach die teile neben
rheinpreußen hafen im wasser der torso
wurde später auch hier gefunden der
antrieb in denen rein hinaus und wurde
dort am genfer entdeckt im februar 2014
wurde hier am rheinufer das erste
leichen teil des ermordeten rocker km
gefunden ist wahr sein arm die polizei
wusste sofort auf grund der tätowierung
es handelt sich um einen hells angel
eine mordkommission wurde gebildet und
die ermittler gaben sieben jahre lang
nicht auf diesen fall endlich zu klären
und haben nun endlich das ergebnis und
wissen was damals hier passiert ist
von dieser brücke hier wurde der torso
und das trübe wasser des rheinpreußen
hafens geworfen deswegen erinnert bis
heute hier diese trauerstätte an den
ermordeten rocker km seine eltern haben
es eingerichtet man sieht mit einem
blumen herz und auch ein kreuz und sie
sagen sie sind endlich froh dass dieser
mord aufgeklärt wird und hoffen jetzt
dass die beiden flüchtigen täter auch
noch gefasst werden
der kronzeuge führte die ermittler der
duisburger mordkommission zu dieser
brücke hier über den rhein-herne-kanal
er sagt wir haben von dieser brücke
betonklötze ins wasser geworfen darin
sind die leichenteile und auch der kopf
des ermordeten rockers polizeitaucher
rückten dann an durchsuchten das wasser
des rhein herne kanals und fanden dann
in augenzeugen beschrieben die
betonklötze darin die leichenteile sie
wurden obduzieren das war ganz klar es
sind die leichenteile und der kopf bei
m&s war dann auch klar km ist mit einem
schuss in den hinterkopf getötet worden
die brutalität der mutmaßlichen mörder
macht bei den razzien den einsatz von
schwerbewaffneten sek beamten und einem
ram panzer nötig
doch noch kann die akte nicht
geschlossen werden denn zwei männer sind
noch immer auf der flucht einmal pro
charakter passt er soll ja die tödlichen
schüsse auf km abgegeben haben denn er
hatte ihn für ein spitze gehalten und
als präsident des hells angels charter
persönlich rache genommen außerdem sein
clubkamerad muster verhindern dieser
wird wegen zweifachen mordversuchs an
einem verfeindeten bandido und seiner
freundin im jahr 2013 gesucht
und im fall begleitet von beginn an
unserer bild reporter frank schneider du
stehst in diesen minuten auch vor dem
landgericht duisburg wir haben vorhin
schon darüber gesprochen ein unfassbar
brutaler fall in deutschland heute sind
also sechs hells angels angeklagt was
erwartest du heute von diesem tag in
duisburg
erstmals zur erklärung wir stehen
mittlerweile im gericht wir sind an
einem nachbarraum des großen
gerichtssaals in dem in wenigen minuten
der prozess beginnt und wir mussten hier
in diesen nachbarraum aus gründen der
sicherheit denn es herrschen sehr sehr
hohe sicherheitsvorkehrungen hier zählen
alle personen durchsucht die ihnen das
gebäude wollen man muss sich das
vorstellen wie in der schleuse am
flughafen muss durch einen
metalldetektoren rahmen über alles
hundertschaft der polizei um das
gerichtsgebäude hatte große
befürchtungen es könnte hier zu einem
auflauf von rockern kommen das ist
bislang ausgeblieben möglicherweise weil
sie auch keine lust auf diese kontrollen
haben vom ersten prozesstag erwarten ja
es wird wahrscheinlich so sein dass
heute nur die anklage verlesen wird und
es hat anträge geben der verteidigung
die vorteile haben eben schon gesagt
dass sie hier auf eine konflikt
verteidigung gehen sie sagen wir sagen
erst mal gar nichts wir sagen auch noch
nicht mal ob sie es waren oder nicht
waren wir bestreiten die tat nicht wir
sagen einfach gar nichts und wollen doch
mal sehen ob diese beweise der
staatsanwaltschaft überhaupt reichen ob
der kronzeuge überhaupt reicht aber eins
vergessen sie dabei offenbar der
kronzeuge hat die polizei zu den
leichenteilen geführt wir haben es ja
eben beitrag gesehen und da fragt man
sich natürlich schon woher soll er das
gewusst haben wenn er nicht eben auch
bei der tat dabei war der
hauptverdächtige ist immer noch auf
freiem fuß er zelebriert seine freiheit
in videos verhöhnt damit die deutsche
justiz wie gehen die ermittler hier vor
welche schritte unternehmen sie
ja wie gesagt er ist natürlich
abgetaucht sie haben den beitrag gehört
er sagt ja selber ich bin nicht
abgetaucht ich lebe sozusagen in
freiheit und genieße das leben aber das
kann natürlich schnell für ihn zu ende
sein der iran liefert nicht aus das ist
richtig und auch in dem fall des zweiten
hauptverdächtigen in bei den schüssen
auf den bandido erlebt in der türkei
wird auch nicht ausgeliefert aber gegen
beide existieren internationaler
haftbefehl und die zielfahnder und auch
das bundeskriminalamt sind natürlich auf
ihren spuren sie gucken genau was machen
sie und sobald sie diese länder
verlassen klicken die handschellen
dann sind sie nicht mehr sicher und ist
hier auch die frage mord verjährt nunmal
nie sie können ihr leben lang das land
nicht mehr verlassen ob sie das wirklich
durchhalten man könnte es auch ein
finanzielles problem für sie werden denn
irgendwann sind vielleicht auch die
ersparnisse sozusagen aus der zeit als
rocker und aus den kriminellen
geschäften aufgebraucht und da muss man
abwarten was dann wirklich passiert ich
habe eben übrigens auch noch kurz vor
dem prozess mit der staatsanwältin
sprechen können mckellar sie vertritt
hier die anklage und wir können uns aber
eben anhören was sie mir gerade noch
wenige minuten vor prozessbeginn erzählt
hat
frau carla heute beginnt das große
rocker verfahren was ist das besondere
an diesem verfahren an diesem prozess
das verfahren ist in vielerlei hinsicht
dass er besonders in fällen von
versuchten oder vollendeten
tötungsdelikten kommt es in der regel ja
meistens nach wenigen monaten nach der
tat schon zu einer hauptverhandlung
jetzt liegen die angeklagten taten aber
acht jahre zurück das sind acht jahre in
denen die kriminalpolizei in duisburg
wirklich herausragende ermittlungsarbeit
geleistet hat was nun hoffentlich in der
hauptverhandlung auch zur
vollumfänglichen aufklärung der
hintergründe der taten oder taten selbst
natürlich führen wird was sind denn ihre
erwartungen jetzt an dem ersten
prozessor und überhaupt man den prozess
die staatsanwaltschaft duisburg ist sehr
zuversichtlich ist auf grundlage der
anklage zu einer umfänglichen aufklärung
des versuchten tötungsdeliktes an dem
ehemaligen mitglied der bandidos sowie
des mordes an km kommen wird erklärt
bekanntlich nicht und die
hauptverhandlung wird sicherlich ein
signal setzen dass sowohl die
ermittlungsbehörden als auch die justiz
alles dafür tut auch lang zurückliegende
straftaten aufzuklären warum hat denn
dieses verfahren so lange gedauert und
was hat dazu geführt dass am ende jetzt
doch zum prozess kommt ja die
angeklagten taten sind beide aus los das
damals in duisburg schweben
rockerkrieges und wie man sich denken
dann in dem milieu gestalten sich
ermittlungen schwierig weil zeugen nicht
mit den ermittlungsbehörden
zusammenarbeiten wollten im fall des km
ist es so dass im 2009 10 an der
durchbruch gelang als ein zeuge sich der
polizei offenbart hat und dank der
wirklich sehr akribischen arbeit der
polizei duisburg ist es dann gelungen
diese aussage auch mit weiteren beweisen
zu bekräftigen weshalb es dann letztlich
im september 2021 zum zugriff kam als
dann auch haftbefehle und
durchsuchungsbeschlüsse vollstreckt
werden konnten
ja und genau um diesen kronzeugen wird
es hier im verfahren gehen er wird erst
im august kommen aber genau das wird der
elementare punkt sein reichen diese
aussagen von ihm reichen diese beweise
die die polizei in duisburg dann in
jahrelanger kleiner ermittlungsarbeit
zusammentragen konnten um am ende die
sechs angeklagten hells angels ihr zu
verurteilen und ob die beweise reichen
erfahren wir letztendlich von der du
hältst uns weiter auf dem laufenden aus
duisburg vielen dank für den moment
frank schneider